democrats now forced to admit what most
americans see plain as day president
biden is a total disaster multiple media
reports have liberals bashing the
commander-in-chief as weak and
ineffective complaining that joe is not
moving fast enough to respond to
multiple crises rocking his
administration one liberal lawmaker
telling cnn that the biden
administration is quote rudderless
aimless and hopeless another saying
quote it's almost like he's hiding he
has the bully pulpit and he's either
hiding behind it or under it i don't
know where he is
and a democratic strategist ripping into
biden's team quote it's infuriating our
house is on fire and it seems like
they're doing nothing to put the fire
out they're just watching it with the
rest of us
and the usually sympathetic media also
bashing biden
there is this sense that things are kind
of out of control and he's not in
command we need joe biden to be present
and to be a leader that meets this
moment i mean do something i think is
the point that people are saying we're
not giving folk anything to be excited
about and we don't have that fierce
urgency of now
and you know things are truly a disaster
when hollywood celebrities jump ship
actress debra messing reportedly fed up
about president biden's lack of urgency
and the administration being unprepared
despite weeks of warning on the reversal
of roe versus wade she also reportedly
claimed credit for getting joe biden
elected
i guess we better do a check on whether
or not debra messing actually got joe
biden elected but jesse i'll start with
you
when they say we need him to be present
and to be the leader is joe biden
capable of that no he never was and i
think big tech and china were like
actually no we we got joe biden elected
uh just his schedule this week is a
perfect example it's largely ceremonial
on monday he has a barbecue for july 4th
on tuesday he hangs some medals around
some hero's neck wednesday he actually
flew to a swing state and gave a speech
on what about the american rescue plan
he passed last year about covid and
tomorrow he is going to langley to
celebrate 75 years at the cia and then
friday he just flies to delaware for
another
three-day weekend
if you're going to give a speech how
about give it about inflation how about
give it about gas prices those are the
most important issues of the day or your
base cares about abortion and guns he
doesn't do any of that at all they want
him to perform the presidency is a
performance if the supreme court comes
down with a major abortion decision you
cannot give a speech fly to delaware and
then take the whole next week and go
over to europe you can't do that the
left wants to see him spitting mad
hands in the air out on the streets
raising hell and he just doesn't have
that in him they want him attacking the
supreme court he doesn't want to do that
he can't attack republicans they're not
even in power they tried the whole ultra
maga thing but it was corny and vague
and now they just put it to bed so right
now they're really saying what is your
plan of action after row and he didn't
have one but they didn't have one either
putting abortion clinics in national
parks that's not a real plan they have
to go to the states and that's where the
action is but under obama they lost like
every single state house in the country
so it's going to take a long time and a
lot of hard work and groundwork to get
back to where they need to be sandra
you're the economist at this table and
you know with people concerned about as
jesse said inflation and the economy
karine saint pierre said yesterday
jump here sorry said yesterday
in talking about the economy she said
business investment do we have it do we
have the sound oh go ahead we've
averaged more than 400 000 jobs every
month for the past
over the last i should say over the last
month three months
we've held steady that 3.6 of
unemployment rate consumer spending
remains strong and above pre-pandemic
trends business investment investment
remains strong and household balance
sheets remain strong the thing that
jumped out at me sandra when she says
household balance sheets remain strong
if that was the case you wouldn't have a
gallup poll telling you that 23 of the
american people have lost confidence in
the presidency monmouth just 10 percent
believe that the country is heading in
the right direction washington post
wants a shift a vibe
shift change from this presidency to
jesse's point
governor pritzker in illinois said it we
want we want this president to get loud
we want this president to fight they
want to see anger angst urgency to the
point on the economy if there was a more
telling point of this presidency the
president sees that the number one
concern of the american people is
inflation and high gas prices what does
he do he goes out and says i know that
that is the priority it's the priority
for us we're doing everything we can to
bring down those prices what does he do
he taps the spr which is the wrong move
that's not how you address the problem
first of all and it has not brought down
gas prices and then what happens reuters
reports starting yesterday
the oil that is coming out of the
emergency reserves in this country is
going where not into the gas tanks of
the american people it's going to china
china it's outrageous and the white
house has asked about it and karine
jean-pierre doesn't even know about it
right at least she says she doesn't well
i believe she doesn't uh
just
all
right
do i need to put a question to you can
he get any lower in terms of the numbers
or has he hit the rock bottom
technically he could go lower i i don't
think he will it's 36 percent or about
there right now i think that's probably
where he'll hover two things that i
wanted to speak about one i think that
this frustration about having six weeks
to be prepared for this is so important
to understanding the psyche of liberals
right now but also a lot of moderate
republicans who would have preferred
that we had some national protections
and we all saw the polling from earlier
this week that you know well over 60
were in favor of a 15-week ban and when
you look at the fact that they're in
some states where you have you know that
the ten-year-old girl from ohio who was
raped and because she was six weeks and
three days pregnant her parents had to
take her to the bastion of freedom that
is indiana to get an abortion you can
understand why people are saying why did
we not have a plan to combat the chaos
why didn't they i don't know i don't
work for the administration but you did
have six weeks
no i definitely don't
don't start that rumor um
six weeks is a lot of time to put
in place plans to lean on state
legislatures and governors to ensure
that people are going to be protected
that you can still order your abortion
pills online that you can cross state
lines etc but there's an interesting
phenomenon going on with the polling so
democrats now are running well ahead of
joe biden so if you look at 538 right
now there have been 10 polls that have
come out in a post-row world and the
democrats are up in the congressional
ballot in all of them so we've seen a
three to four point swing in democrats
favor and i think that that's really
interesting and a reflection of what's
going on in this push back against what
people rightly feel are extremely
extremist republican policies so i
wonder how much campaigning joe biden is
going to end up doing for the midterms
if someone like raphael warnock is up 10
on herschel walker in georgia maybe
people will just go without him john
fetterman in pennsylvania well well
that's yet to be seen but greg how do
you respond to that i don't
okay that's not fair you may not respond
to you all the time i have a really good
joke about yogi bear no all right so
what you're seeing right now
i think what we're looking at is a large
hole
left vacant by the january 6 hearings so
now you see why the january 6 hearings
were so desperately employed and so
desperately necessary for the democrats
right because if you once you remove it
what you have is a gaping lack of
leadership a gaping lap lack of optimism
common sense wisdom we have a giant hole
where leadership should be that is why
so now when you when you look at the
january 6 cuz hearings because it's
coming back you'll now know why it's
there because when you take it away
this is what you get you get this
grim
testimony about the nature of this white
house so the media has chose to amplify
the hearings the same way they
de-amplified the hunter biden laptop
story before an election this is what's
happening with this it's before an
election it was before an election then
this is why no one should believe or
trust anything that's coming from the
same cabal that did the hundred biden
laptop and also did this hearing it's
the same thing that doesn't mean that
the republicans are just gonna skate
through this what bothers me is i don't
like the
i don't like the dancing on the grave
preliminary kind of celebration they
they've never there's never been a
better time for the republicans you've
got the democrats are an awoke paralysis
right the loudest most unhinged voices
control their party and they've
relinquished any concern for parents to
the republicans the republican party is
now the parents party i think we
mentioned that early on during those
school board hearings when they said
this was a great opportunity and that is
what has happened but you can't just
cluck about it you've got to be
persuasive to the voters you've got to
take it to them and you've got to have
practical solutions about the economy
and practical solutions especially about
crime because we haven't spoken enough
about that the crime that is going on
all over it's not enough to say ha ha we
actually have to have some reason what i
mean us i mean normal common sense
non-woke people and i i include
democrats in that i think that this is a
time for moderate democrats to come back
and and kind of like
uh rediscovery rediscover the joys of
common sense hmm
and the truth is we've been waiting to
hear from them but we haven't hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else